hallo zusammen schön guten Tag
willkommen zu ZDF heute live
Großbrand auf vor der Küste der
beliebten Ferieninsel Ameland aktuell
steht in der Nordsee ein Auto Frachter
in Flammen bei dem Brand kam ein
Besatzungsmitglied der für mental
Highway ums Leben die anderen konnten
mit Hubschraubern und Schiffen gerettet
werden der Frachter hat etwa 3000 Autos
geladen möglicherweise wurde der Brand
durch ein E-Auto verursacht die für
mental Highway war unterwegs von
Bremerhaven nach Ägypten als das Feuer
gegen Mitternacht vor der
niederländischen Küste ausbrach
und die große Gefahr ist jetzt dass der
Frachter singt dass er zerbricht und das
eben zu einer Umweltkatastrophe kommen
könnte darüber wollen wir gleich reden
ihr könnt uns eure Fragen eure
Kommentare schicken einfach in die Chats
schreiben oder eine E-Mail schreiben wir
sprechen gleich mit dem Meeresbiologen
Thilo mag von Greenpeace mit Last Hova
von der Gesellschaft für
Sicherheitstechnik Schiff Sicherheit
Ostsee und wir schalten jetzt erstmal zu
unserer Reporterin Isabel Schäfer hallo
Isabel
hallo
Isabel wir erwischen dich kurz vor der
Fähre nach Ameland der stärkste gleich
ein wo eben gerade viele ihren
Sommerurlaub verbringen was kannst du
uns zum Stand der Löscharbeiten sagen
also zunächst mal kann man
sagen dass das Schiff unglaublich heiß
ist und niemand das Schiff betreten kann
deswegen kann man eben nur von außen
arbeiten und man hat die Sorge dass wenn
man zu viel Löschwasser an die falsche
Stelle bringt dass dann das Schiff an
Stabilität verliert und Kentern könnte
deswegen versucht man eben derzeit nur
mit Wasser von außen das Schiff weiter
runter zu kühlen man hat mit Hilfe eines
anderen Schiffes das Schiff derzeit
relativ gut stabilisieren können und man
hat jetzt auch gerade vor kurzem hier
noch ein weiteres Spezialschiff
hingeschickt was bereit steht für den
Fall dass doch Öl austreten sollte aber
die Löcher Arbeiten sind eben weiter
schwierig und man versucht hier um jeden
Preis zu verhindern dass das Schiff eben
singt und da gibt's eigentlich jetzt
zwei Optionen die ähm weiter in Betracht
gezogen werden das ist einmal dass das
Schiff hier weggeschleppt werden könnte
über Arland aber dafür müsste erstmal
jemand antworten und die andere Option
ist dass man den Frachter einfach
komplett ausbrennen lässt und das könnte
Tage oder auch Wochen dauern
es heißt ja dass ein E Auto in Brand
geraten sein soll das steht noch nicht
fest aber was weißt du darüber
das bestätigt noch
[Musik]
keinem liegt nah und deswegen war das
auch eigentlich ein schneller Schluss
der gezogen wurde weil das Feuer eben an
der Stelle ausgebrochen ist wo diese 25e
Autos standen aber bestätigt ist das
noch nicht
wie dramatisch war diese Rettungsaktion
der Crew also wir hören da sind Menschen
30 Meter in die Tiefe gesprungen sowas
macht man ja nicht wenn es nicht
unbedingt nötig ist
ja genau das ist auch das was die Retter
gesagt haben dass man sich das mal
vorstellen muss aus was für einer Höhe
das ganze Geschehen ist dass man das
nicht leichtfertigt tut und ich glaube
alle hier die die dabei waren haben
beschrieben dass es eben sehr dramatisch
war dass die Leute vor Ort nicht gut
aussahen die gerettet wurden und das
ganze liegt wohl auch daran dass eben
diese unglaublich hohen Temperaturen
erreicht wurden die jetzt eben auch die
Löscharbeiten so schwierig machen
vielen Dank Isabel Schäfers für den
Moment du schaust jetzt dass du deine
Fähre nach Ameland bekommst und dann
sehen wir dich um 7 Uhr in den heute
Nachrichten mit dem neuesten Stand der
Dinge danke dir tschüss
tschüss ja und damit gehen wir direkt
weiter zu Lars Tober von der
Gesellschaft für Sicherheitstechnik
schiffsicherheit Ostsee sie sind Experte
für Brandbekämpfung auf See damit wir
uns das vorstellen können wir gehen die
Rettungskräfte jetzt vor
Innenangriff ist quasi ausgeschlossen
wie schon erwähnt weil keine an Bord
kommt
die Aktivierung der fest installierten
Löschanlage hätte durch die Besatzung
erfolgen müssen warum das nicht
geschehen ist kann man jetzt natürlich
nur mutmaßen und jetzt haben wir nur
eine Chance von außen im Prinzip die
Außenhaut die Hülle so runterzukühlen
dass wir im Prinzip die thermischen
Spannung gerade im Bereich des
wechselganges verhindern das heißt da wo
das kalte Wasser und dann der heiße
Stahl Zusammentreffen wenn man sich die
Bilder anguckt wir sind jetzt von oben
gezielt in Deck 6 ungefähr
10-6 ca hat das Schiff also es ist noch
ein bisschen lose ne und das ist auch
relativ günstig dass er dran von oben
nach unten sich ausbreitet weil die
Rauchgase natürlich den Innenraum auch
ich sag mal füllen energetisieren den
Sauerstoff verdrängen so dass man
wirklich eine Chance haben könnte dass
das Feuer liegen kommt das war jetzt
offenbar nicht mehr möglich dieses
Schiff zu betreten und da irgendwie
Löscharbeiten voranzutreiben wenn auf so
einem Auto fragt da Feuer ausbricht
worin bestehen dann die größten Gefahren
für die Crew
naja wenn das im oberen Bereich
geschieht haben wir hier das Problem
dass wir natürlich an Oberdeck die
Aufbauten haben das heißt die
mannschaftsunterkünfte die Brücke und
auch die Rettungsmittel die ja hier ich
sag mal vorderen Teil auf beiden Seiten
die Rettungsboote man sieht das
angeordnet sind
ob die dann noch zu erreichen sind dass
es eben dann die Gefahr ne wenn die
obere das obere Deck ist das sogenannte
garagendeck wenn da natürlich eine
starke Hitze entsteht und Flammen
ausschlagen kann ich die Rettungsboote
nicht mehr erreichen wenn man sieht das
dann Bild und ja dann bleibt dann nur
noch springen das ist eben das Problem
und wie gefährlich ist der Einsatz jetzt
für die Rettungskräfte auch die sind
erstmal relativ sicher weil die sind auf
ihren spezialschriften die haben ihre
Wasserwerfer die also bis zu 30 40.000
Liter pro Minute wasserwerfen die haben
meistens auch Vorrichtung und sich
selber zu schützen durch Sprühwasser
also da besteht keine Gefahr weil selbst
ich sag mal erwartete Explosion oder
sowas aus Angst
im Inneren der Schiffes werden immer
noch durch die Außenhaut aufgehalten
was wäre denn jetzt bei diesen
Rettungsarbeiten so ein Worst Case
Szenario
da das worst-kill-szenario ist das ja
das Schiff irgendwelche Öffnungen
außenhautöffnung außenbords Armaturen
aufgehen und er dann massiv Wasser nimmt
und dann im Prinzip eine Schlagzeile
geht und dann kennt und über die
Auswirkungen werden wir dann gleich noch
mit dem Meeresbiologen sprechen aber
haben solche Frachter denn irgendwelche
frühwaren Systeme oder
Löschsysteme um brennenden dieser Art
irgendwie begegnen zu können
die sind schon nach Vorschrift
ausgerüstet wir haben aber natürlich
hier eine Spezifik bei diesen Schiffen
wir haben auf normalen Schiffen
feuerzonen das heißt das Schiff ist
eingeteilt in mehrere drei vier fünf
feuerzonen die auch baulich dann
getrennt sind das heißt auch hier wird
ein Widerstand gegen das Durchbrechen
des Feuers irgendwo geschaffen diese
Teile die Autotransporter kann man sich
vorstellen großer Schuhkarton die sind
also offen von vorne bis hinten von
Steuerbord und wenn es auf so einem Deck
brennt gibt es also keine
möglichen Barrieren die jetzt das Feuer
oder auch die Idee die Wärmeübertragung
aufhalten dazu kommt dass es eben ganz
normale Stahl Decks sind die also
größtenteils auch nicht mal thermisch
isoliert sind
teilweise haben wir dann lushaugen durch
alle Decks also kleine Öffnungen wo die
Fahrzeuge verlasht werden so dass das
auch die Decks an sich nicht geschlossen
sind und das eigentlich ein riesengroßer
Hohlraum ist ne wo sich natürlich Wärme
Rauchgase Hitze alles perfekt ausbreiten
kann das klingt jetzt so als ob es
gerade jetzt nach diesem Unfall
überlebenswert wäre diese
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen zu verschärfen
oder
da ist man auch schon dabei ja es geht
also darum die Löschanlagen vielleicht
noch mal zu überdenken
also auf diesen Schiffen haben wir
entweder CO2 wie im normalen
verschließbaren Laderäumen
vorgeschrieben oder aber wir haben einen
sogenannten high expanischen Form man
ultraleicht Schaum das kann man sich
vorstellen wie das was man auf der
Badewanne produziert der dann innerhalb
von einer halben Stunde dieses Deck
komplett Fluten soll
inwieweit das praktisch rentabel ist bei
der hohen thermischen Beanspruchung und
bei der bei der
steckhöhe von
2,10 oder so wo dann die Autos drin
stehen inwieweit sich der Schaum dann
richtig effektiv ausbreitet lösch
wirksam ausbreitet naja ich möchte da
mal ein leichtes Fragezeichen dahinter
setzen und gerade in diesem Fall wäre es
ja sowieso zu spät
Jan B hat eine Frage auf Youtube könnte
man das Schiff nicht auch wenn es brennt
in einen Hafen ziehen und daran würde
ich die Frage gerne anschließen was
passiert denn jetzt mit diesem Frachter
also die Taktik besteht eigentlich darin
wenn er darauf sehr sicher liegt ist das
eigentlich eine der günstigsten Plätze
ich komme von allen Seiten ran ich kann
reagieren ich komme auch mit schweren
Einheiten ran die also wie schon erwähnt
sehr viel Wasser werfen können an Land
muss ich in eine Bier schleppen das
heißt ich habe dann auch landen hier ich
habe Rauchschwaden rauchgasbelastung
auch für vielleicht Ortschaften in der
nähe
ich glaube es gibt kaum Hafen Kapitäne
die das also Beifall klatschen wenn man
ihn so ein Schiff an die Pille legt und
dazu habe ich natürlich dann das Problem
ich kann auch nicht mehr wirklich
reagieren ich kriege das also nicht mehr
in den Wind gedreht oder sonst irgendwas
und je nachdem wie die Windrichtung ist
habe ich dann unter Umständen auch gar
keine Chance von der Pia zu arbeiten
wenn eben die Rauchgase auch die Tiere
getrieben werden und selbst mit
Drehleiter neue Teleskop Fahrzeugen bin
ich dann sehr gehandicapt auch mit der
Wassermenge ne also wenn er sich sicher
liegt ist es immer einfach ihn auf sie
ich sag mal ganz erlaubt kalt zu kriegen
okay und dann wird das Schiff eben
danach in einen Hafen gebracht in
welchen auch immer okay jetzt steht ja
im Raum dass ein E-Auto in Brand geraten
sein soll das steht noch nicht fest aber
die
Berichte gibt es Isabella hat ja vorhin
gesagt bestätigt ist das noch nicht aber
es gibt ja Warnungen vor erhöhtem
Brandrisiko durch diese
Lithium-Ionen-Akkus auf Schiffen und es
gibt ja auch eine Reederei aus Norwegen
die sagt bei ihnen fahren keine Autos
oder Hybride mehr mit wie schätzen Sie
dieses Risiko ein
ich kann das nicht bestätigen dass
E-Fahrzeuge das von Zeugen eine
besondere Gefährdung ausgeht ich sag mal
so wenn ich einen PKW
Brand im Griff kriege egal ob an Land
oder auf einem Schiff dann ist es völlig
egal ob seine E-Auto ist oder ob es ein
konventionelles Fahrzeug ist das Problem
ist nicht der Akku da unten sondern das
Problem ist die erhöhte Brandlast in
modernen Fahrzeugen ich sage mal so als
gutes Beispiel wer sich noch an die gute
alte Ente erinnern kann da das
gescheppert wenn man die Tür zugemacht
hat heutzutage habe ich also kiloweise
Kunststoffe in diesen Autos verbaut und
das bringt eben auch diese starke
Hitzeentwicklung um diese diese
langanhaltenden Brände bei den
Fahrzeugen das hat also mit dem mit dem
Akku an sich wenig zu tun dazu kommt
dass der Akku sehr sicher verbaut ist im
unteren Bereich verbaut ist auch ich sag
mal mechanisch extrem geschützt ist dass
man kann sich das also vorstellen der
ist in einer in einer sehr stabilen
Stahlhülle der kann ja auch krass Tests
überstehen die DEKRA sehr viele Versuche
gemacht also man kann das Auto
theoretisch sechs Meter fallen lassen
ohne dass der Akku Schaden nimmt und das
ist natürlich eine auch eine Barriere
gegen das Feuer Diener normaler Benzin
oder Dieseltank zum Beispiel nicht hat
der aus Kunststoff einfach so unterm
Auto hängt
es gibt noch eine Frage im Chat von
Norbert er fragt kann man den Brand
nicht mit Gas wie Argon Stickstoff oder
Kohlenstoffdioxid löschen
also wie gesagt es gibt Schiffe die
haben als fest installiert CO2 Löcher
Anlage das kann man sich aber vorstellen
bei den großen Schiffen sind das nicht
mehr einzelne Flaschen sondern es sind
große Tanks in denen das CO2 gelagert
wird und die muss man an Bord auslösen
wenn aber keine Antwort kommt oder wenn
das vielleicht schon geschehen ist und
das CO2 dann irgendwann sich durch
öffnen
und auch im Hafen nicht so einfach
nachgefüllt
und dann gibt's noch eine Frage von
Heiner wie lange kann das Schiff noch
brennen also könnte dieser Frachter
jetzt jederzeit auseinander sprechen und
dann sinken nein auseinanderbrechen tut
so ein Schiff sowieso nicht also ich
hatte schon erwähnt die Schwachstelle
ist der wechselgang das heißt das Schiff
kann komplett Ausglühen und bleibt dabei
schwimmfähig die die kritische Stelle
ist wirklich der wechselgang also für
den Laien da wo das Schiff von Grau nach
rot übergeht da wo die Wellenrand
klatschen weil da habe ich die
thermischen Spannung da kann es dann so
wissen kommen da sind die außenbords
Armaturen also Seewasser und so weiter
was aus Maschinenraum rausgeht und wenn
da Öffnungen entstehen
durchbrandeinwirkung dann läuft das
Wasser in das Schiff und das kann es
eben nur bis zum bestimmten Punkt ab
dann verliere seine Auftrieb seine
Stabilität und dann singt das halt
ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich dass Sie
mit uns ihr Fachwissen geteilt haben und
auch so rüber gebracht haben dass wir es
nachvollziehen konnten vielen Dank
tschüss tschüss ja die Gefahr einer
Umweltkatastrophe ist also nicht gebannt
und darüber möchte ich jetzt mit dem
Meeresbiologen Telemark von Greenpeace
sprechen hallo
wir hören eben dass die Gefahr besteht
dass dieser Frachter eben sinken könnte
warum ist das so gefährlich für die
Umwelt was würde dann passieren
also die Gefahr in der Frachter sinkt
besteht darin dass das ganze Öl was der
geladen hat der ist ja gerade erst in
Bremerhaven losgefahren das heißt die
die treibstoffspeicher waren noch voll
dass dieses Öl oder Diesel bestenfalls
dass das austritt und das wäre aus
Umweltsicht aus ökologischer Sicht eine
absolute Katastrophe die
Strömungsrichtung in der Nordsee ist
Richtung Osten das heißt ein Frachter
der jetzt vor hollandaviriert und und Öl
verliert der ähm das wird dazu führen
dass das Öl über kurz oder lang auch in
die deutsche nordwege kommt und dann ins
Wattenmeer und das Watten mehr ist ja
nicht von ungefähr UNESCO wird Naturerbe
das ist ein einzigartiges Ökosystem wir
haben aktuell ca 1 Millionen Alter enden
und Brand Gänse die flugunfähig sind
weil sie sich geradeaus an das heißt sie
verlieren ihr ihr Fehler Kleidung Baumes
neu auf wenn die jetzt von einer
Ölkatastrophe betroffen werden das wäre
eigentlich der wäre tot und das sind nur
die die ich jetzt gerade nenne die in
der Mauser sind wir erwarten jetzt auch
viele 10.000 800 tausende wartflügel aus
der Artist die im Wattenmeer Rast machen
auf ihrem Weg in die Winterquartiere
also eine Ölkatastrophe in der Nordsee
im Wattenmeer ist das letzte was wir
jetzt gebrauchen können in diesem
ohnehin katastrophalen Sommer
2023 wo ganz Süd-Europa brennt und und
die Erde überall
also das ist ein Schiff mit 3000 Autos
wir haben vorhin gehört wir reden also
über erhebliche Mengen ist denn das
geladene Öl die größte Gefahr für die
Umwelt
was jetzt gerade passiert ist hat ja der
der brandexperte gerade auch gesagt
indem ich mit mit großem Interesse
zugehört habe sind zehn Decks die stehen
voller Autos und diese Autos brennen
gerade auch da ist viel Kunststoff drauf
das heißt es sind chlororganische
Verbindungen wie zum Beispiel PVC ähm
daraus entsteht Dioxin es wird viele
Kunststoffe werden da sein die mit
Flammschutzmitteln umhüllt sind auch da
entstehen kloorganische Verbindung das
geht jetzt alles in die Umwelt das
betrifft jetzt nicht direkt die die
Nordsee und das Watten mehr aber das ist
alles das was jetzt in die Atmosphäre
gelangt und dann über kurz oder lang
über mehr oder auch über dem Land
abregnet also gut ist das nicht
es gibt eine Frage von alpin Wolf wo
liegt das örtlich nächste
Naturschutzgebiet
das
örtlichen nächste Naturschutzgebiet ist
dass das Wattenmeer
das ist trilateral in Dänemark
Deutschland und Holland die Frage ist
auch insofern gut weil es hat sich im
niederländischen Watten mehr eine
eiderentenkolonie gebildet über die über
die letzten zehn Jahre die ähm
hunderttausend Tiere ausmachen und das
werden die ersten die betroffen werden
es wäre wirklich katastrophal wenn das
Watten mehr betroffen wäre das geht
nicht nur um Vögel es geht vor allen
Dingen auch um alle möglichen Organismen
die im
Meeresboden Leben was wohnen und Co und
alles was davon abhängt also viele
Fischarten im Falle einer Ölkatastrophe
würden auch die Gezeiten dafür sorgen
Erbe und Flut dass sich dieses Öl
weiträumig verteilt und dann ist die
Frage beschäftigt uns das kurzfristig
wir gehen davon aus dass wir die Jahre
wenn ich sogar Jahrzehnte dauern das
sind so die Erfahrungen die wir haben
zum Beispiel bei der die water Horizon
die havariert ist wo in Florida die
gesamten großen küstenbestände betroffen
gewesen sind die Waren mechanisch oder
chemisch eigentlich nicht zu reinigen da
muss man auf ja die Kraft der Natur
setzen und das dauert erfahrungsgemäß
sehr lang
also wir wollen es absolut nicht hoffen
aber angenommen es würde sich ein
Ölteppich ausbreiten was würde dann
passieren
die Gezeiten würden diesen Ölteppich
weiträumig verteilen nicht nur in der
niederländischen sondern vor allen
Dingen auch in der deutschen Nordsee das
Wattenmeer wäre betroffen
viele viele 100.000 Millionen Organismen
in Watten mehr alles was am Boden liegt
dort Fische Schnecken sie Sterne vor
allen Dingen aber auch der gesamte
Vogelbestand das Warten Meeres wäre
betroffen und da sind zurzeit eine
Millionen Alter entenbrand Gänse in der
Mauser die betroffen werden und wie
erwarten jetzt den großen Vogelzug von
arktischen Wort Vögeln die traditionelle
Rast machen in der im Watten mehr um
weiterzuziehen in ihre Winterquartieren
genau das hatten sie gesagt die Frage
ist was was könnte man denn machen also
wie würden Organisationen wie Green
Peace in so einem Fall am aktiv werden
also wir haben als 1998 die
palasavarierte und tagelang durch die
deutsche Nordsee trieb und Öl verloren
hat wir haben dabei geholfen veröte
Vögel einzusammeln das wirklich Hand
überhand Vögel wenn sie verölt sind
haben die Eigenschaft sofort sich
anzufangen zu putzen und vergiften sich
da dabei und wir waren damals mit vielen
Aktivisten dort um bei den
Reinigungsarbeiten zu helfen die Vögel
mit einem zusammen und was anderes würde
uns auch in diesem Fall nicht übrig
bleiben ist ein wirklich sehr sehr
langes Unterfangen in andere Länder
setzen auf den Einsatz von Chemikalien
um das Öl sozusagen aufzulösen aber das
wäre in in diesem Fall nur bedingt
möglich also sobald das Öl zum Beispiel
in den Salzmarschen ist kann man das so
auf gar keinen Fall mehr entfernen
wir haben eben von Herrn thoba gehört es
gibt eigentlich keine ausreichenden
aktualisierten Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
für Brände dieser Art auf Frachtern was
müsste da aus ihrer Sicht passieren
also wenn man jetzt sozusagen drei
stufig Vorgehen würde dann müssen wir
jetzt erstmal dieser Brand gelöscht
werden das wurde gerade schon gesagt wir
müssen zweitens dafür sorgen dass das
Schiff sicher in Hafen kommt ohne dass
das Öl verliert aber wir müssen uns
drittens vor allen Dingen Gedanken
darüber machen ob wir nicht alternative
Schiffsantriebe brauchen jenseits von
fossilen Energieträgern das muss
tatsächlich die Zukunft sein wir müssen
raus aus der Verbrennung fossiler enter
Energieträger und rein in die
erneuerbaren Energien und da muss es
auch Mittel und Wege für die
Schifffahrtsindustrie geben ich schaue
gerade mal noch was im Chat los ist es
gibt eine Frage von Tilo kann man das
Schiff nicht Richtung Land ziehen um die
Löscharbeiten auszuweiten das hat vor
ihnen hat Toba gesagt dass eigentlich
keiner brennende Schiff in seinem Hafen
haben möchte und insofern ist am besten
ist eben vor Ort diese Rettungsarbeiten
weiter voranzutreiben
Norbert und cremeschnitzel Fragen im
Prinzip das gleiche wer haftet für diese
Schäden und in welcher Höhe also mit
Sicherheit am sind jetzt auch eben
etwaige
naturschäden gemeint
die naturschäden die überhaupt zu
beziffern ist erstmal ein großes Problem
was was kostet denn ein veröltersievogel
und wie will man wie will man das
beziffern beziehungsweise entschädigen
weil der ist ja nun schließlich tot das
ist eine ganz eine ganz wichtige Frage
ich ich kann man kann sehr davon
ausgehen sie sprechen mit einem
Meeresbiologen von Greenpeace aber das
ähm die Schiffe entsprechend versichert
sind und diese Versicherung greifen
werden ansonsten ist die Tatsache dass
überhaupt jetzt Schlepper schon vor Ort
sind ist eine Erkenntnis sozusagen aus
den Havarien der Vergangenheit das Hawa
Rico mando hat sich in Deutschland
gegründet und die haben jetzt dafür
gesorgt dass die Situation so wie sie
ist auch tatsächlich günstig ist das hat
uns gerade der Experte auch schon mal
gesagt ähm was im Falle einer Natur kann
passieren würde und wer für diese
Schäden aufkommt das ist eine
hochspannende Frage finde ich an dieser
Stelle aber erst mal sekundär
letztendlich muss man nach dem
Verursacher Prinzip vorgehen und das
wären ganz offensichtlich auch die
Schiffsbetreiber hier
sie beobachten die rettungs- und
Bergungsaktionen ganz genau
lässt sie das Vorgehen der
Rettungskräfte hoffen dass das gut
ausgeht oder glimpflicht zumindest also
ich verfolge ja den den Liveticker also
die ganze Zeit so wie sie so wie sie
auch momentan sieht es so aus als wenn
das Schiff in Position gehalten werden
könnte das ist sehr sehr günstig das
Schiff brennt da entsteht viel äh da
entstehen viele Schadstoffe das ist für
die Umwelt nicht gut aber das sorgt
erstmal dafür dass die Situation stabil
ist und ähm jetzt ist es erstmal an an
in der Hand der Sicherheitskräfte dafür
zu sorgen dass die Situation auf stabil
bleibt und der Vater nicht havariert und
und Öl verliert
weil das wäre die größte Katastrophe
da mag ich danke Ihnen ganz ganz
herzlich für das Gespräch machen sie es
gut tschüss sehr gerne
ja und damit machen wir Schluss mit
unserem Stream zum Brand des ähm Auto
Frachters vor der niederländischen Küste
der Ferieninsel Ameland ich wünsche euch
noch einen schönen Abend macht's gut bis
bald tschüss